I'll go Ambrose no I name is Perry pack
or should I say default swag it's a game
that should be funny and there's a hand
with a flag on it wait what
okay let's forget they're dancing
without any music I'm gonna add some
appropriate music because of that [ __ ]
make noises like that when they dance is
fabulous oh no not my friend turtle the
quad Oh No too bad I'm dancing over here
where did he go better on over here for
no [ __ ] reason it possibly could have
went there if he was looking that way
out whatever alright so this is a mario
clone ala rage as far as I'm concerned
so we'll see about it you know X at
exactly how to jump okay coins are bad
the [ __ ] are you talking about coins are
great seriously what the goddammit what
okay alright so now I know [ __ ] it's a
long way down use the platform
what def what it's like everything
you've learned about platforming games
this is [ __ ] you okay the flag okay the
flight so spikes are good back okay
press Z to run
okay thanks fire god dammit I forgot to
pick a [ __ ] coin there we go what the
[ __ ] does that have to happen seriously
oh [ __ ]
hello who says he's dead before you'd
recognize okay oh god I feel bad for
tricking you have a cupcake fatty oh
thanks
seriously Danny I don't know what's
wrong with you man who has a turtle as a
friend anyway I don't trust that cupcake
we shouldn't have trusted tight
you piece of [ __ ] in watch the universe
it's cupcake a bad thing I don't
understand Oh God coins everywhere I got
more cupcakes
[ __ ] you cupcakes take the sword are
really [ __ ] really okay
we beat the first no cupcake god damn
cap cake all right let's continue this
game is actually kind of cool I'm
curious to see what else I got a troll
on our asses win you better get a
running side why this is fine right yeah
are those coins down there [ __ ] points
oh okay
what Pierce is confused here that's a
[ __ ] spikes man this is the only
collectible coin you're really going to
avoid it
why would the game lie to me I don't
understand that
I thought we were friends game Oh Shh
coins alright so he's good evil so he's
fine I was supposed to write him
probably guy oh yeah okay all you need
is [ __ ] hearts man I've goddamn hearts
and cupcakes I hate you okay I made it
that's myelin cloud is a ridiculously
safe sure sure man
let's get it okay but man
just gotta go past these and then shut
up okay evil flower how do I get past
you keep moving to stay alive how are
you supposed to know that someone
[ __ ] tell me anyway let's keep going
try to keep your limbs attached all
thanks those are bad right and they
don't do [ __ ] good jump and nothing
happens okay spikes let's just go over
the spikes Oh God not the clean set for
guy I keep forgetting all right oh that
works okay cool you what noises thanks
why why this is the champion jump bad
yeah he's definitely good oh god damn oh
so I'm sorry I'm really I'm a better
give us races and now I have to die
before in the Hoying okay here we are
all right what do we do now oh god that
was worth it oh god I got that thing
[Music]
what where am I no more hearts okay
there we go we did it right oh quit that
dancing you look ridiculous
what I don't understand why did the
marshmallows kill me oh god that cards
oh oh oh thank god
okay there we go
I'll quit that dancing you look
ridiculous
I have to agree with their sign on that
one at least so now we unlike this
little level it's a bonus level
oh god Marshman how the [ __ ] Mike I
don't trust it oh my limbs collect coins
nice that's it's wonderful
only one more coin level far go slow you
may make it what does that even mean
and then you jump down here no really
you might make it you dick oh god
alright we go here then oh not the heart
but even touching it okay there we go
Oh God
anything but that what Oh God well at
least I collect that a lot of [ __ ]
coins oh there we go
[Applause]
you should buy yourself something nice
with the hose [ __ ] you what if I go down
here okay oh yeah that's right fist your
ass mr. cloud and he respawns
my flag I don't even give a [ __ ] about
the gold anyway [ __ ] that bonus madman
one does not simply walk past I do
Oh goddamnit cupcakes fine no oh god I'm
more of you [ __ ]
is he nice he has to be nice right what
do I do
I noticed that Dan I noticed that such
cupcake much flavor that's how you do it
that's how you do it I suck man you
little [ __ ] cavernous plants think you
are very tasty so very tasty well eat me
then come on a nice slice what the hell
oh god no no no please be gentle with me
hearts why
okay time the devil Oh God - Jorge
oh god no boy ah they're everywhere
this is like now left what is happening
[Applause]
there we go that was easier spikes press
jump to bounce higher no jump higher no
jump higher fields idiot right get
sucked in there we go there we go oh
here we are
oh no turtle the trot don't worry she's
just gonna fabulous here it's not a bad
thing I swear oh no he put him on a hill
how dare he
she I don't know what let's be honest it
could be anything no no anything about
the cupcakes I think my white is this
but if they go on the spikes gosh oh oh
she don't look oh gosh
okay we're fine what come at yellow
[ __ ]
there we go
right in the ass oh no not that
oh why do I even care about that title
it's not nearly as cool as I am goddamn
I hate cupcakes what when when can you
sister I don't understand [ __ ] is going
down [ __ ] is going
I'll show you swag off your ass and
Britney Spears [ __ ] many feet
dyke that's so your whole thing humming
huh lemon now ha ha so jab let me get
off now sir chance Jax what what what
it's going on so easy when you know how
to kill that [ __ ] what what what
no now's your chance
no chance yes [ __ ] is dead [ __ ] thing
my pink fluffy ass cloud that's right if
you obey me now [ __ ] where are we going
what what I thought they were on a my
son what hatred all you piece of [ __ ]
now we can continue listening to our
favorite song [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] but
hoes and tricks lick on these nuts and
suck the dick get the [ __ ] out after
you're gone and happen to my right and
make a quick run alright so that was
they fold that I really like the idea so
far it's pretty cool I think they have a
lot of stuff they could add but I'm sure
they have a lot of ideas that they want
to add as well so yeah if you enjoyed
this leave a like I really appreciate it
hit the sky cover with today and I'll
see breasts the next one stay awesome
love you can the fireworks stop please
[Music]
Philippe intended